بعد سبع سنوات على انقطاع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بينهما تعلن السعوديه وايران
في بيان تشترك فيه الصين المستضيفه للوفود
عن وصل ما قطع
كله شيء كشف عنه اليوم ويضع الطرفان الامر
في خانه تفضيل الحوار
سريعا تلاحقت ردود الفعل مرحبه بكل ما
يخفف التوتر في المنطقه
ويعزز الاستقرار
وفي التفاصيل اعلنت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه ان الرياض وطهران يتفقت على
استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه واعاده فتح
السفارتين والممثليات الدبلوماسيه في غضون
شهرين
وذكرت الوكاله نتوصل الى هذا الاتفاق جاء
عقب مباحثات جرت في الصين مع الرئيس
الصيني
اضافتنا المباحثات جاءت رغبه من طهران
والرياض في حل الخلافات بالحوار
والدبلوماسيه ونقلت الوكاله السعوديه عن
بيان سعوديا صينيا ايراني انا وزيري
خارجيه البلدين سيجتمعان لترتيب تبادل
السفراء
نقشتي سبل تعزيز العلاقات واشارت الى ان
السعوديه وايران اتفقت على تفعيل اتفاقيه
التعاون الامنيه بينهما كما اتفقت على
احترام سياده الدول وعدم التدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه
واخذها مستشار الامن الوطني السعودي مساعد
بن محمد العيبان قال ان ترحيبا بمبادره
الصين يات انطلاقا من نهج التمسك بمبادئ
حسن الجوار وتعزيز الامن كما قال كبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين ان محادثات
السعوديه وايران وحوارهما في بجين نصر
للسلام
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان قال ان سيدنا العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
بين بلاده وايران ياتي انطلاقا من رؤيه
المملكه القائمه على تفضيل الحلول
السياسيه والحوار واضاف الوزير السعودي في
تغريده ان دول المنطقه يجمعها مصير واحد
وقواسم مشتركه تجعل من الضروره ان تتشارك
سويا لبناء نموذج للازدهار والاستقرار
بحسب تعبيره اما نظيره الايراني حسين امير
عبداللهيان فقال ان سياسه حسن الجوار التي
تنتهجها حكومه ابراهيم رئيسي تسير في
الاتجاه الصحيحه
امينو مجلس الامن القوميه الايرانيه عن
الشامخاني الذي كان مشاركا على راس الوفد
الايراني في بجين قال ان طهران اتفقت مع
الرياض على فتح صفحه جديده بناء على مصالح
البلدين والامن الاقليمي واضاف ان طهران
تامل ان يخلق هذا الاتفاق توازنا في سلوك
القوى الاجنبيه بالمنطقه حسب تعبيره
فكان نحن هنا منذ سته ايام في بيجين
واجريت مباحثات مع نظير السعودي توجت
باتفاق تطبيع العلاقات اتفقنا مع السعوديه
على فتح صفحه جديده مبنيه على مصالح
البلدين والامن الاقليمي وعلى تعزيز
الاستقرار بدلا من تفاقم التوتر ونامل ان
يسهم في احلال الامن والتنميه بالمنطقه
وخلق توازن في سلوك القوى الاجنبيه
وابعادها عن منطقه التي دخلتها دون اذن
نتطلع الى ان يسهم ذلك في ترسيخ علاقاتنا
ليس مع السعوديه فحسب بل مع دول المنطقه
والعالم الاسلامي العدو لا سيما الكيان
الصهيوني يشعر بالاحباط والياس من هذا
الاتفاق